there's a sense in which as we create
those environments we actually change
ourselves as a species there's this a
set of ideas that's known as
gene-culture co-evolution and the idea
is that we create certain kinds of
cultural environments those kind of
cultural environments advantage certain
ones of us making those of us that are
born with certain abilities better off
which then leads to those environments
being created even more let me give you
some example of that the most famous
example of this is something known as
lactase persistence so many people not
about half the world can adults can
drink milk the other half cannot they
get lactose-intolerant well why can you
drink milk as an adult have you ever
thought about that like why why are you
capable of drinking milk as an adult in
our ancestral state actually up till
about 10,000 years ago only babies could
do driven to digest milk because only
babies had milk babies would suckle at
their mother's breasts and have milk and
then they'd be weaned and then they
would never drink milk again there'd be
no milk to drink there was therefore no
reason for any adult to be able to
digest lactose which is the principle
sugar in milk because there was no
lactose in your diet you didn't
encounter milk so human beings were able
to digest lactose when they were babies
they lost that capacity all human beings
when they got to about two or three or
four or five when they weaned they no
longer were able to just milk so the
enzymes in their body were programmed as
it were to only work when they were
infants well about between 3 and 9
thousand years ago in multiple places in
Africa and in Europe human beings
suddenly domesticate animals we
domesticate milk producing animals like
cattle and sheep and goats and camels
and now all of a sudden there's a supply
of milk around us because of our
cultural innovation because of the thing
we invented we created the domestic
breeds now we have milk now therefore
those among us who are mutants who were
born with the ability to have our
lactase the enzyme that digests lactose
persist into adulthood this is known as
lactase persistence those of us who had
that would have a survival advantage
because we could have another source of
calories that the rest of the people in
our group couldn't consume they couldn't
drink milk like we could
and we had a source of unspoiled water
during times of drought we could drink
milk everyone else had to drink this
filthy water that they didn't have
access to so those among us who had
these qualities could reproduce better
survive had a survival advantage it
turns out that this has happened several
times this has been well documented the
genetics of this has all been worked out
several times the last three to nine
thousand years because of a human
cultural product we have evolved to be a
slightly different genetically and it
doesn't stop with cows I think that when
we invent cities about over 5,000 years
ago we so we did we invent agriculture
about 10,000 years ago it's debated
exactly when we invent cities but
between five and ten thousand years ago
we start having fixed settlements
earlier you and I were talking about
population density and having to live
with other people which is not our
ancestral state not packed not with
other we always lived as a group
socially I think that as we invent
cities people with different kinds of
brains are better able to survive in
cities so now that we've invented cities
where advantaging people with certain
kinds of brains and therefore I think in
a thousand or two thousand or five
thousand years
just like the milk example there'll be
different people as a result of
something we humans manufactured that we
made mm-hmm and I could keep giving you
examples of this there's a in the book I
have an example another example of a
there called the sea nomads that they
they live in the Philippines these are
people who don't live on land they live
on houseboats that sail around the
Pacific for thousands of years they've
had this lifestyle and they die for
their food dive so they forage on the
seabed they are the world's best free
divers they spend hours per day under
water they can hold their breath longer
than anyone else and they they do it
nothing except with weights and wooden
goggles they dive down into the seabed
and forage and they hunt they hunt
underwater with spears okay they hunt
underwater with Spears mind-boggling and
but they have evolved have different
spleens and different oxygen metabolism
than you and I hmm
so those among them that could survive
the dives fed their families made more
babies and now we think this happened
2,000 years ago they're different the
Hun's that couldn't died so their
invention of a seafaring way of life
their invention of a way of living at
sea the boat technology the the
spearfishing technology the invention of
those technologies creates an
environment a cultural environment
around them which modifies natural
selection and changes the kind of genes
that those people have